[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre je paie h quand
tu es avec moi de dôme plantes
aujourd'hui on reçoit au lit prime aux
entrepreneurs au tour maintenant avec
ton nouveau hit août un autre ouvrier
tas de beach club
g si vous aimez ce que vous entendez
oubliez pas de vous abonner à notre
chaîne et le sans commentaire est ce que
vous pensez à ajouter la conversation on
aime ça interagir avec vous au lit merci
d'être ici
merci je textait matin c'est moi cio
tout pour moi c'est un plate forme que
j'ai beaucoup de misère à étudier avec
elle vient de montrer un matin petit
tenté d'utiliser and we protège ses
péchés comme partout depuis quatre ans
j'ai asseyé tout régler autour je sais
pas quoi faire avec ce qu'on dit je
viens de partir la chaîne le croit
dernièrement commencé
comment ces actifs sait mais personne
qui me subjugue aucun vidéo danse
correspondrait gergaud m'a soutenu c'est
un bon début
exactement à chaque jour mais pas de
casse surtout ben je trouve ça dingue ou
pharyngées baird de france allez vous
est arrivé tu arrives ici ici c'est chez
nous tu arrives ici avec tout ton swag
contenait bien entendu été évitée si
j'ai vu c'est la ligne qui vient d'être
lancé des produits dérivés de bitche dvd
comme missionnaire de la can est ici ça
s'est littéralement poppin par partout
c'est quelque chose que tu avais
envisagé quand tu es dans toute l'
aventure du beach club c'est quelque
chose qui est arrivée un peu comme un
cheveu s'assure par azor aubin c'est
vraiment quelque chose que tu avais en
tête quand tu t'es lancé dans tout seul
c'est un business le depuis tout jeune
je me faisais foutu dire je suis dans
tout au tout
c'est sûr que quand on a acheté le
bichonne avec ma famille on était
vraiment focus sur le beach club mais je
le savais qu'avec les années j'ai encore
plein d'autres possibilités puisque c'en
est en étant un peu d'histoire je vous
la fais vite vite de bitche des buts et
c'est un slogan que les étudiants de
l'église pendant la semaine de porter
leur froc le cap l écriture da [ __ ] des
rues d'abidjan vous dit pas tout ce
qu'ils vont puis la première année
tournage et le beach l'homme à fin de
l'année ces initiations sont 5000
complètement fini les gens devaient guéi
qui font le party voilà dix ans par
décret beach des rues des bus comme je
les monte lagacé terrain c'est un beau
slogan et à partir de là ça c'est tout
me a dit boulay parce que dans vie tout
début de matinée la cbi si c'était seul
concept et le bus ou systar brain
partout que ce soit en asie
walt est vrai que tu sois je pensais pas
que ça deviendrait aussi gros mai
j'étais sûr que lebron allait marcher
parce que c'est un mode de vie justement
ces canadiens mais ça pour ça mais c'est
comme ça on y envoie même qui boivent
pas l'habitude j'ai vu des mêmes s'ils
apportent pas ils m'envoient gens parce
que c'est parti fidesz lajos kosa un bon
mode de vie puis tout ce qu'on met en
vente avec ce nom là dessus fonctionne à
cause de ça parce qu'on veut vivre levaï
pis c'est on aime tout ce travail blum
fait que l'impression que finalement
beach club devient plus une grosse
machine de promotion pour les produits
en épicerie puis les produits
je voudrais ben franchement c'est rendu
de contraindre la cgem des saints
auraient passé tellement à groupe
surtout ces boissons là on a la chance
d'être distribués par le plu aux
distributeurs qu'il abatte ce concours
un appui bonne marque de ceux à qui on
est dans une semaine maintenant 6000
points de vente on est rasant 1.5
millions de canettes avec le monde son
genre
c'est démesuré les démesures ebe jamais
jamais en passant à vendre comme ce même
aux autres on est les boissons numéro a
vendu dans cette catégorie là et au
québec puis parce que justement pieds
tellement de monde qui n'agite qui
viennent pour bishop qui vient aux
jeunes aux biches l'homme
1 mais chacun taylor soit le chercheur
d'histoire lui maintenant de chicoutimi
wever est du nouveau brunswick ne m'ont
tenu la main de la boîte en ontario on
n'est pas distribué en soi mais la
montée de descendre à gatineau pour
aller chercher et que c'est un monde
qu'on est guéri pitonner livré demain
d'autres que lui on a sorti du duc
étaient nombreux ce soir au québec on
est beaucoup à un le blue beach volley
beaucoup aux filles au beach fax tempo
le club aimerait sûrement répondre lynch
dvd pour que may et gros lot c'est que
tu le saches ou non c'est bien débuté et
où le lauquet
je trouve sexy il est accusé leblanc
dans ce moment de transport que le
bishop be cette année je revois fois
plus d'argent avec beach débuté que le
bishop et je suis bien content puisse
avoir du sens à mon avis le monde au
québec même si un nom anglais 100 % qui
s'y passe dans le fond tu es le fait de
faire venir des gros artistes
ça vous fait comme votre pub gratuite
dans le sens de la paix 150 programmes
et ap sauf que le téléjournal à tous les
journaux en parlent qui les a fait
connaître les beats
c'est la première année que la plaine
johnson il vient beaupuy première 2015
que puis je disais mon budget pour la
pub plutôt utile comme trop qu'on se
paie pas des go soeda pitard pas besoin
d'eux puis c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé puis ça a été tellement une
bonne idée un pari mais un pari énorme
est elle une bonne idée ça qu'on doit
faire donner plein de monde qui était
pas faire grand talent dont je me
rappelle clairement dans marianne qui
arrive en hélicoptère dans l'eau lucky
gspr chercher en bateau classé qu'en
france c'est toi que pendant le montre
j'ai une anecdote est là dessus dame
s'en vient
après la première fois c'est lui qui
demandait de revenir
soit il est payé pour faire reporter
fait tant qu'à faire la partie venant
des places qui aiment l'année l'été qui
est venu je pense qu'en 2000 size le
phénomène dans des urnes a frappé le
québec genre oui mon fond puis
facilement sa demande qui est terrible
les bouteilles d'alcool et hélicoptères
pour beaucoup il boit de la coroner fac
tout qu'est ce que tu vois ça à table
c'est pour le monde qui les entoure
notre entourage le monde qui vont
toucher avec mes deux belles filles qui
se promène avec qui
ils demandent des hélicoptères soit fait
que j'appelle des femmes qui ont des
hélicos on pouvait aller chercher
ouais et comment ça fonctionne avec
transports canada c'est très complexe à
aborder les feuilles de rupture faritany
saviez qu'il a l'autre lycos pause pour
aller poser le reste de sa gamme
pendant que l'autre son hélico fait du
surplace lui de se livrer la pop plongée
malin il sait pas s'il ya de l'eau les y
auriez mushi dans halo dans le bateau
mon secours et si comme mes pieds 12 ou
le grife club paul soete plan bush ça
paraît pas au le meilleur plongée
d'argent 25 points qui plonge jeter
comme s'il faut que dans des sacoches le
coup d'envoi jacques pin depuis deux
semaines après transports canada une
panne ou nous donne une âme en peine
je capotais puis finalement le plus
handicapant négocié qu'il ya des appels
dans besoin d'eux c'est lui qui ouvre la
partie pour moi qui lui ai sorti de
l'auberge avec ses anecdotes besoin
c'est un destin un domaine qui ont fait
parler du beach club en bien ou en mal
mais au début c'était vraiment au début
j'avais un petit problème avec
l'identité de biesheim au volant dit que
je voulais vraiment changer l'image
ouais mais avec le temps j'ai compris
que ça s'arrête là changer il faut
qu'elle le monde qui viennent
l'acceptent juste une place de portée
puisque c'est l'amour ni juge pas les
dix années qu'il juge proche est à greg
c'est tout de la même clientèle tant que
le fait qu'on soit jugé james otis a
fait je prends mon temps je suis là pour
me faire juger
ouais enfin que je me serais fait que
j'ai pas besoin d'un plafonnement la
seule chose que je veux c'est que quand
le monde ils viennent chez nous ils
aiment les produits et leur expérience
afin que que tu m'aimes tu m'aimes peau
ou quel thème l'image produits bio sont
souvent par il fait que c'est ça ouais
j'ai si tu allais
télé au beach club 7 mg pas eu
l'occasion d'y aller puis t elle c'est
ça c'est ça le surprit a été surprise de
vraiment aimé son expérience dans les
titres tout comme l'idée préconçue où
étudia way tidm je pense au cpie brest
pointe l'appuyer par max et comme dans
la législation
ces malades parce que c'est pas parce
que c'est chez chichi nous excusons
encore mais j'espère que c'est au québec
pile au québec là on avait besoin d'une
place d'un même projet qui là québec à
qui fait chaud le monde devienne fou
vous savez les terrasses mot d'ordre est
le fait de tout le monde et dont
l'ouverture des fins que celles à la
folie l'été qui un beach club y en a un
puis je pense pas qu'il ait de la place
pour n'avoir deux parce qu'on appel à la
population pour ne surtout pas de
l'argent au québec pour former des
grosses vedettes comme cela at the beach
club comme ami ami pts adopté les
touristes sont pas habitués aux nerfs au
québec pendant un beach club même si là
je te dirais que plus que 15 % vient pas
du canada le nombre de choses que 15% du
monde
c'est énorme dans le monde sont en
voyage du club puis williams pour ce jeu
te dirais que
le québec surtout montréal on est très
réputé il ya énormément énormément de
matches reportés l'été puis ils viennent
tout chez nous surtout mettons à partir
du mois de juin c'est la folie pseudo
parce qu'il ya des batchs de paris qui
viennent de vénus division mobile chez
elle à pointe-calumet m'a fait une faute
au cheo beach des villes comme c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas la prétention d'être
chic on n'a pas la prétention d'être
venus
on se la joue pas on a des paniers je
n'ai pas hors de prix 0 ça dépend tu
peux être vraiment hors de prix ou tu
peux payer l'accès c'est la grosse
séance parce que j'ai fait pas mal de
beach club de clowns dans ma vie pas
avant d'ouvrir ce qui à chaque faute sur
des bancs la même ça coûte cher aux
personnes qui a pas d'argent qui peut
aller avec vue sur la piscine ça coûte
trop cher je serais rentré ça coûte 150
du lac au beach club
ce que le monde qui ont de l'argent le
mans qui n'ont pas d'argent m c'est que
tout le monde en lançant ses doigts
parce que les gars et les filles qui
arrivent souvent dans les tables en
octobre sortie dans le monde depuis deux
ans après qu'est ce que je vois son
temple et mieux du dancefloor bouteille
à 5000 pieds comment ça ça n'existe pas
ailleurs
ce que j'en ai flottes puis j'en ai pas
vu avec c'est ce que le monde
m mais ça fait de la corneilla personnes
qui me faisait tellement beau
bishop fadam ssf accès à un autre vague
complètement qui est ce parce que j'aime
aussi c'est pour ça que je ne sors plus
que l'image ses poteaux sociale et parce
que quand même que je fais ça par les
housses et italie puisqu'elle face à pia
d'hakim fois c'est bien correct mais je
te dirai quel 99% du monde casques
rouges me dit ce chercheur vient puis le
monde qui veulent pas volé ils me le
disent c'est ces malades mais c'est pas
pour moi que je comprends le vibe tout
se trouve que c'est pas pour moi afin
que je respecte ça ça pour ça mais la
personne qui me disent thaçi on ne peut
pas être achètent et au soleil
au québec il fait 30 degrés
martin garric soin de mes gosses qui
sont devant toi sur une plage à moins
qu'à l'humain au bout de 40 des actifs
des vrais faux panier déjà partiellement
télévision on est on est question des
gens on s'assume pas pour ça et beach
bbcb ce billet il y avait un accès
gratuit
ben ça fait deux ans qu'on fait ce qu'on
a un problème d'un programme
d'ambassadeur qu'on surnomme beach boys
on s'assume le genre c'est quétaine
ses trench easy un pied
c'est comme un peu l'idiot de 8h55 et n
sauf que toutes les filles de l'accès au
bus gratuites à des gratuités du monde
mais ça c'est celui ci est bonne c'est
gratuit c'est 75 following ce serait les
réseaux sociaux ça dépend un gars comme
cette année on appris du monde y avait
500 personnes comme dumont dit annonçant
minky ces deux on est reçu comme 2000
candidatures
on en apprend 60 à comprendre mais tout
au tout payant ce moment là le micro
influenceurs est tellement populaire
parce que tu voyais ces battantes 700
personnes qui tue son appât du gain de
la femme tes amis vois que tu vas pas
gagée par le bishop pour être beach boys
4 go way lady byng puis un rinçage et
bizzbee qui sait ce que le mot son camp
boire c'est comme la ils sont encore
plus ils se disent ah mais quand même je
pourrais peut-être bon sens et breschel
la créatrice d'habitude sur 19,5 soit en
année c'est vraiment juste pour que le
monde à une femme qui disait je pense on
était de fou puis c'est gratuit puis
j'ai une fan fait que non c'est ça ça
fait partie de tout ça fait partie aussi
de l'hiver cac ont justement on lance
d'événements gratuits à part ça c'est
pas j'ai pas après arrêté à toutes les
influences qui ont un sentiment
d'appartenance mais ils font ils font
partie d'équipés de la grande famille du
beach club fait que
la philosophie c'est vraiment
l'inclusion tout le monde tous les
horizons autour de celle de mon vraiment
pythie gratuit au beach est bien moins
que zéro chez puisqu'elle est blanc
comme un drop il ya les gros groupes qui
posent lafonta toutes les jo puis comme
sparring dédoublement s'il dit qu'on a
triché c'est j'aime aussi préserver un
plus haut à genève parce que ça fait
justement qui entremêle autre chose si
c'est que maintenant dans mes vacances à
miami au mexique ou à l'erreur tout le
monde était en bikini toulon est infect
personne juste personnes au québec il ya
aucune place à pozzo tout
quel effet ils peuvent sortir leur
bikini qui allait profiter du soleil
tout ça avec 500 personnes
on juge cho parce que c'est au québec
mais on est au mexique qu'ils iraient
copie personne dit jean mi ré beach club
en a ras la douche parce qu'on rentre
chez elle
piscine au piège à 69% du bond qui
achètent des billets en ligne qui vient
de l'île de montréal
j'ai pitié quand tu regardes mettons le
mile end tout seul les points rouges se
voit même plus le mile en fac c'est le
monde qui me disent tu est un doggy bag
chips et des hipsters jusque là oui
c'est vrai les numéros mon match trois
cabanes et à tous et tribales
souvent les anciens vraiment dit il
tout le monde a estimé lundi un juge par
mr c'est quelque chose que je pense
qu'ils te bien continue notre site et on
s'était rencontrés la première fois où
elle est vraiment patrice bernier
puis c'est vrai c'était par laitiers
pour être chercher des ambassadeurs pour
le beach club finalement te prie lpp à
l'anis puis ça de mon oeil à moi ça m'a
semblé être un énorme succès non je sais
pas quel point à quel point ça c'est
transférés en même temps en temps je te
demande tu m'as tu vu sont révolus et en
fait c'est d'abord à sion je te dirais
que avec l p puis à l'anis j'ai même pas
j'ai même pas regarder l'impact de vente
de bière et n'était pas du tout pour ce
repas pour ceux du tout c'était pas que
le monde quand qui viennent au beach
club il ya un sentiment d'aller voir des
amis aussi bas que témoin j'ai 32 ans je
parle peut-être moins ou 18 19
ça parle normes exactement être apparue
18,34 fait que je leur parle aussi mais
si ça fait quatre ans que leurs paroles
vides
on ne parle mieux on a besoin de
changement pas que je voulais vraiment
avoir deux supports oslo qui sont là
puis lp balanais sont capables que
rubens phelps a été très bon pour
l'autre ces mairies maisons tant
qu'invité à cause de ce on dirait que
tout le monde s'est dit justement à ya
du monde quand j'aime que je pense était
à la naissance jamais le monde pensait
qu'elle viendra au beach club band sera
là nous devrons comment y aller mais ce
sont des salaires est couché le parfum
de l'année à pleurer alors je m'ennuyais
puis on part deux piges peut-être ce que
tout le monde qui vient au budget dix
fois pour des radios on a une grosse
grosse famille et au bishop son rôle
dans le prochain cabinet cette année
deux jours où elle habitait avec son
veilleur y habiter ou puisqu'il y
accoucher chez nous pendant trois mois
la capi mini paradise en anecdotes -
l'ancien goal of money dos et padraig
huawei et pitt et jonah hill et à québec
m'embaucher son réseau la coop ont la
bougeotte le c'est comme un musée
plus votre les affaires de patin web
c'est tout c'est pas un corset enfin que
cai a commencé à bosser chez nous jeter
comme le bateau roi
zhu qui a vraiment pas de besoin de rien
envie rapport aux autres femmes jouent
de la musique man pied chanceux il ya
bien sûr la plage fac qhd rencontré pour
la première fois son pari
c'est avec un ton faible ce mariage bail
de six tables ou ce qu'ils sont versées
chez nous tu as roi c'est chez vous avec
des trois pics tout le monde tout le
monde cédric a été l'autre clé touché
avec être pire on ne touche au jour de
plage tous les jours toutes les invités
qui viennent votre futur de la guitare
de ces malades parce qu'il ya tellement
de monde que tous pensaient jamais qui
viendront beach club qui sera mons la
fin de la journée puis ces gens quand
j'ai croisé claudia bouvette aux biches
l'homme jeté comme ok j'ai réussi à
inviter tout le monde fait de l'auto oh
et puis elle a eu une fournaise du fait
que west à coup c'est une belle étape je
pensais vraiment l'été que l'été
rappelle l'été d'ouverture habituelles
on a vraiment comme on est vraiment
devenu grand public tout le monde s'est
dit ok ça semble avoir pris une culture
jean hohl la cei notre line up ce qui a
vraiment changé on le fait mais beaucoup
d'artistes pas pousser d'un beaucoup
d'artistes latine ont l'âme on aime
beaucoup beaucoup sont justement il fait
chaud trop riez pas cette année ça il ya
eu plusieurs on a eu
on n'a eu rien me go ce qui était fou on
annule c'était fou l'impression que j'ai
déjà out parce que ça c'est pendant la
fin de semaine la saint-jean puis nous
on épargne dans un festival à ottawa qui
s'appelle escapade qu'on y faire nominer
habituellement on est ouvert pour le
rapide parce que c'est une compétition
du tout l'impression j'aimerais ça faire
un genre de camping tout le monde dans
le trou au piano tout le monde tout le
monde sait comment puis je sois capable
une coupe de
le chanteur je chante ici g berne pour
l'année prochaine qui sait donc pas ce
que le manque sur norrath faible jamais
selon michelin puis des artistes à tout
le monde qu'ils sont venus ici l'été
comme huawei capitaine julien breton
artistes préférés sur une plage de beau
et la folle ambiance incroyable la
soirée raquel c'est tout autant succès
qui est karine karine pour une première
année je compte on ne fait presque 4000
personnes
petit il faut dire aussi que des salles
de spectacles mettant une note aux
biches abl soldate désagréables comme
tombouctou plateforme nommée il ya du
monde
ouais mais tu es salaam au gardian
n'aime pas mais que bien des dettes à
laval la nouvelle place belle qui ont
fait une job incroyable qui ont un genre
de de ne pas y aller festival mais enfin
que ça existe pas de 4000 le monde et
réalise pas commencer beaucoup de
personnes au québec taq a des goûts de
chambre devant 80 personnes qui ont payé
c'est pas comme on fera cours gratuits
puisque le monde ont payé pour ne
l'avoir fait que une méchante 200 pour
le pour le québec puis l'année prochaine
je ferai grand festival du monde
bon je pense que la séquence parce que
je pense que ce taux est gagnant puisque
toi ça d'autres côté vraiment mon genre
de faire venir le rappelait que cette
hargne et tiësto qui chargent je sais
pas combien ils ont caché quand même
parce qu'ils sont habitués
puis courage à 5 l'acalf active comme
tout le monde est gagnant avec
d'encourager de la scène québécoise
c'est que vraiment pis je pense que le
mot nyon ils ont vraiment réalisé qu'on
voulait pousser beaucoup beaucoup les
uns québec hausse pendant la plus grosse
agence de dj québécois on a une
vingtaine de dj qu'on fait jouer partout
au québec
ces sites ou des trucs pas qu'on parle
de paume et concepteur on sait aussi
bobby gîte on est tellement d'affaires à
parler quand on en parle parce que son
bouquet partout fait que tout le monde
le sait dans ce milieu
sauf que enfin jouer on fait jouer je
pense et 22 ou 23 dj toutes les fins de
semaine que ça soit saint georges à
rimouski partout même en ontario n'a que
ça c'était cool en effet on les fait
découvrir et puis on les aide à produire
et aussi pilar les pensions ne fait rien
un concours de dj amateur
18 ans et moins le dj qui a gagné
l'année passée s'appelle d'agencés jouer
au beach club et jouer avant les grands
noms ces écarts en pin au québec il ya
personne sauf nous qui peut donner
d'exploser comme ça parce que avant les
gros gros didjob seulement un crime
c'est vraiment pouvoir longtemps par
maître martin garric soit inquiet ce
taux qui vient il ya tout le temps un
groupe rappelle que c'est lui qui dit
moi je le fais pas jouer avant moi parce
que et je le pousse dans mon agence mais
nous on est tellement ouvert longtemps
qu'on commence de bonne heure avec les
artistes québécois
exc c'est vraiment cool sur leur cv car
qui dit j ouvre pour martin garrigues
spurs au québec ça existe pour sochi
bufala une belle porte une belle écoute
une culture qui apparemment d'autres
endroits où s'exprimer le tilt dm je
dire où lady g apport au beach club non
il ya un bond à montréal aussi un new
city gas l'homme et comme je te dis
c'est tellement pour vendre autant sa
louve à 11h le monde arrivait minutes sa
ferme à trophées qui ont pas le temps va
jouer dortmund qui demande qui vont dans
ces places là ils vont pas voir la main
avant ils vont le dj la richesse qu'ils
le pensent qu bishop d'arriva midi
l'artiste jean quatremer active tout en
muscles et du temps mine de nier tout en
déjouant les ballets temps il prendre un
drink 109 à bronzer tu parles ou dix
ados avec tout ce fait qu il ya des
affaires à faire
puis le 4 octobre le choc a mouse
puissions faire masse est petit on va
après tandis qu'un botella 1h30 12 ans
aximum
le canon le concept le concept de des
clubs
la troisième chose oui il ya personne
qui soit quatre minutes tous les jeunes
travaillent aux fans qui étaient couchés
à c'est encore mieux de karaté tu viens
pour une bonne brosse avoir dimanche
puis je te dis pas trop mal avec 5,6
biche début des spectacles 600
spectateurs
c'est une niche des en aide aux bois de
l'eau c'est là que ça me fait penser
qu'il s'est séparé sérieux comme ça
comme sujet mais mes pauvres est si on a
tant parlé des boissons sucrées des
médecins avec le folk ou est-ce que la
différence entre un but éviter parfois
nous on n'a pas de nrj de hockey c'est
la méga différence qui on est à six
points 5 % à base de 12 heures tous pour
ça qu'ils prenaient des photos un
shotgun 12 pour 5 claquin trois secondes
énergie en même temps c'est comme ma
femme c'est juste que c'est ce point
sensible cela canada est grosse mais
j'ai eu je pose jamais la
surconsommation parce que c'est vraiment
parce mai
une date a atteint moi j'aime bien sûr
de votre coup c'est ça c'est que ces
mêmes parce c'est même pas ça tombe
raide présence brent beach club a rien à
voir avec excès de défoncer la gueule
vous taissy jamais de la vie tu vois
quelqu'un au beach club qui a l'air
complètement c'est le candidat il y en a
comme dans tout ça pour ça un crossover
games canadien pas de cap
c'est sûr que chez nous y en a ça arrive
mais la majorité du monde je peux et on
aurait de la place au québec qu'il faut
il de plus métis que tu consommes à
l'aube des clôtures moi j'espérais
pouvoir latino puis on a à cause de ça
pour faire la prévention de fou on a une
infirmerie sur place on nage en tant que
personnes par jour des docteurs les
analyses nallo dont est équipée non pis
en pis on fait ça on fait ça pour faire
plaisir aux mon épaule oui parce que on
est une place qui a beaucoup de monde
tout seul sauf que justement c'est en
effet le parti chez nous est-ce que je
devrais me donnait matin j'ai besoin
d'un hymne à l'eau parce que lui voire
complètement défoncés pour page sauve la
vie s'avère souvent le monde qui sont
comment arracher
il songe en effet ya j'ai fait si j'ai
fait ça j'ai deux camps ne seront pas
non plus annoncé on est combien on fait
vraiment vraiment attention on fouille
on a une sécurité terrible on a tout au
tout
on a des secouristes notamment des jours
pas prendre dans la main je te disais
c'est pendant les jours même je prend le
micro je buvais de l'eau gazeuse comme
on n'est pas la personne c'est un
challenge à la wii mais avant nous si
c'est juste que nous on est tellement
surmédiatisée
quel est le monde on dirait qu'ils
attentent jeu ce qui arrive quelque
chose mais y arriver
tu vois osheaga qui l'a fait le festival
à montréal qui rayonne
internationalement jeu c'est la bonne
j'ai aussi dans les labos s'il y en a
partout paquet il faut arrêter de
capoter avec s'appuie la conscience
sociale aussi là dedans c'est que mon
schiller je t'aimais je t'aime je t'aime
je t'aime je te mets dans un contexte
que tu vois passer une belle journée
sous la gauche est de ma faute je
t'adore cela pourrait bien avoir sonné
les autres soient responsables mais
rendu le thème en est pour que tu sois
intelligent aussi que puis ils ont les
mêmes problèmes et à l'impact de
montréal
c'est n'importe quoi faire demandez-leur
% du monde déclare t on paye tout le
temps pour le rhin pour ça les lois sont
faites à cause d'un pour cent qu'ils
sont stupides et que c'est peut-être là
faut etc et oao beach club à part ces
piles à tous les festivals sont
interminables
c'est un coup dur pour ça que mon chez
vous pour imager la première chose que
j'ai vu ça une fois chacun dans ma vie
l'an passé la première chose que j'ai
vue en rentrant c'est une fille comme le
marché qui se fait traîner par deux amis
avec jean raimbault pipop après le bond
aussi souvent c'est que si ils vont pas
dans un festival à l'été ils viennent
pas de douche phobie chubb pas qu'ils se
disent ok ça c'est ma fête semaine moi
je vois je fallait partir en vacances
good maintien rendu le et je le répète
haut et fort tout le temps
faites attention puis soyez responsable
du stand by
6e su séduire on répète on répète on
répertorie perdre pied le monde des fois
qu'ils sont la plaie qu'est vraiment
arraché
donc elle ne sera pas de bon sens
blessure tombe d'abord puis 99% du monde
sont belle lurette pour le 1 pour ça moi
j'ai une question pour toi parce que
j'avais lu dans un journal un article
et puis dans l'arctique se démarquer
olivier prime aux propriétaires du beach
club refuse ou au décidé de pas se
prononcer sur ce puis je voir si tu veux
te prononcer sur le projet mais sur le
spot l'histoire ddm ns oui qui eux
avaient je pense qu'il serait manqué
tout le monde il y avait un parti de m
joes je me rappelle plus ou via public
canadien
beaucoup ont en effet après un but gag
qui voulait aller dans le camper au
beach club poker je pars mais je lis
tout le monde sait ce que c'est que ça
semblait dire dans le journal que c'est
tout tu disais je veux pas rien droit
parce que j'ai aucune je dois donner un
autre exemple
mettons au centre bell higgins canadien
est ce que la personne qui fait les
réservations tad qu'un que la personne
l'appel à édicter dessus un criminel sur
un site et un billet de 20 des tarifs
puisque ce qu'on fasse la police est là
on engage des services de police de deux
montagnes
on a une très belle relation avec les
goys pas aussi devant les autres ils
s'en vont à leur table ils paient leurs
affaires comme tout le monde
uche compris pour l'image tout seul mais
ils vont à l'épicerie aussi son sens
belle ils vont à l'impact est bon
partout puis leur ont parlé un jour mais
tout le monde voit partout notamment des
piscines s'ils ont quelque chose à se
reprocher ils m'ont soir étaient ils
pensent de ma politique - j'ai rendu le
sait pourtant récent c'est pas mon genre
ces pourcentages est tellement d'avoir à
faire c'est pas moi qui s'occupe booking
pas que c'est choquant
j'ai un micro en dessous puis qu'est-ce
qu'ils font chez vous et tu vois tout et
ça jeff monson qu'est ce qu'il faut sans
doute se demander c'est cette
connaissance qui est un groupe ds qui
s'en sont le qu'est ce que tu fais des
dollars au t4 barge est obligé d'être
mais je prends vraiment bougé tolérer
tout le moment ne sont pas déplacés son
jeu
c'est un sujet c'est un sujet pas de
tabou mais au québec mais partout dans
le monde
c'est un sujet pour le propriétaire de
la place où le la les personnes qui
gèrent injuste aux gens de place le que
ça soit leur jeu part de n'importe quel
ce soir restera que ce soit n'importe
quoi cc c'est un peu tabou c'est juste
que comme s'il faut que ça s'arrête et
c'est pas moi la réunion rien à se
reprocher d'être le jeu face aux bataves
rennes qui dira la dot l'alarmé se noue
on étale à zéro tout le monde et
fouilles à l'entrée il n'y a pas de
passe-droit iront payé leurs billets
comme tout le monde te sopi c'est
correct puis j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup
de journalistes qui m'ont appelé pour me
dire à moi mais ça demande ni il faisait
un jeu faisant il ya un peu du temps
avec la boxe la boxe - la promotion de
la fête d'un combat de boxe j'ai fait de
la promotion d'un combat de boxe thaï
beauce et puis jean pascal kit estime
qu'elle connaît depuis trois semaines
avant l'événement se loge de steve qui
est un ami exactement un ami d'un ami
médecine et qui vend des boks m'appelle
team challenge c'est sûr parce que ces
cadets cellphone dire on parle du 99%
besoin pour ça c'est le fun est tout le
temps dans la cave le monde et donne la
môme et caillau leur % qui sont gays ont
des questions ou de sous l'appareil du
jour je me défile pas c'est juste que
c'est une malade mardi quelque chose à
dire que s'il ya eu des des biens
journalistique met sa demande mais on
enchaîne morceau je me rappelle
après que soit venu une journée sma
rappelle pied comme puis comme ça il
paraît que tu le savais je te comme le
step ou remarques challenger nature
genre tu as tu rien d'autres à écrire
pour la ville ils sont passés et ça
allait fermer la route le cac étaient
400 dans une ferme n'ont même plus
combien parti chez nous il ya eu jean 3
4 go je te mets du nouveau brunswick
personne du québec karine ce pas que le
supposé rassemblement catastrophe chez
nous à 400 personnes
le post le journaliste jamais puis la
machine puis ça fait parler ça fait
tiquer il y a personne après qu il m'a
dit ah et puis le procédé est un journal
et gt line d'ailleurs parce que j'avais
des engagements ailleurs fait que j'ai
eu et j'ai même pas été le fait que
lorsque la jeunesse ma peine je sais pas
je te police et pour ben non j'ai 400
employés jugent pas loger de la job des
personnes âgées une logique que non je
pense que c'est plus un sujet que qu'est
le monde que ce que vous mangez
journalisme aussi va appeler aussi vu il
veut juste que tu dises quelque chose
qui va donner un gage un de ses hôpitaux
on est tellement médiatisé et nous avant
d'aborder des bons l'avait dit j'ai on
va l'aider arrange ça me fait rire parce
qu'au québec on a encore et encore
l'image de ce timbre est l'inventeur
outils dame a few pts se rappelle
olivier guimond puis j'ai une sainte
martine que je vendais des arrageois 14
- c'était un afghan dénonce pippo de
savoir qu'on a bien fait rire quand
j'avais vu ça parce que juste d'un point
de vue extérieur d espèce de lien
blizzard qui a été fait puichéric
c'était probablement juste pas fondées
s'était tiré par les cheveux extrêmement
de la france et que les allées la
compagnie de sécurité qui fait presque
tout les bons à montréal connaissent
toutes les gauches comme ce parce que
les croûtes les côtoie partout l'accueil
le journal s'est peut-être vu le gars en
avance et ramène tout ce mémo c'est une
compagnie de sécurité que j'engage avec
le gars porte je le connais mais je ne
connais pas aux facultés sommes en
essais
parce qu'ils salamanque et ses 600
hommes dans tous tes journées le ça
ressemble à quoi parce qu'on la sent
quand on est à remplacer le partant de
l'argent sale la foule intense mais il
doit décider de gestion derrière ça
faire lui aussi est ce qu'il fait plus
bureau bas tout est vraiment legault qui
dans le monde qui fait le parti je fais
je fais les deux une grosse équipe
justement mon endroit préféré qu'il me
suit partout des là je te dirais que mon
rôle c'est vraiment d'être public mais
c'est drôle de monde qui me disent c'est
parfait ces centres ainsi maj lequel
j'entretiens et je fais tout le temps le
principe tout ce dont je suis le plus
plate parce que je travaille 7 jours sur
7 avec le soin aux jeux partout 20
minutes couchés
c'est tout mon entourage qui fait porter
à ma place et que s'ouvrent les
suivaient des comptes qui brasse plus
qu'elle me suis baladée story c'est là
que ça se passe pour le moins c'est très
correct mais là je serais parti comme
tout le monde il n'y a pas de faire les
parties mais c'est très rare quel est le
matin je suis un pauvre parce que je ne
peux pas être un mouvement ça m'arrive
comme tout le monde mais je travaille
petit au biscione vous allez même dans
les vosges par quatre scooters 8 heures
puis et puis j'ai pas le thème j'ai cinq
semaines personne chez nous c'est pas le
temps que s'il arrive quelque chose se
défoncer
je n'étais pas là d'un bilan du québec
lui je sais pas si tu es je sais pas si
c'est une image ce qui passe qui propose
qui montre ses qui fait je pleure je
pense pas tu peux pense pas que
physiquement tu peux mener ce qui laisse
paraître
c'est toute la nuit mais ça fait
longtemps que le législateur des coûts
avec le merveille à montreux promet un
voyage avec lui partout puis à
comprennent ayem que son image de tango
qui est entouré de philippe qui prend
des photos et des bouteilles mais il
faut que la photo ait pris de carnac
sablon biais des cas qui est venu chez
nous à l'aube du sado après cinq ans de
filles qui voulaient aller glisser pisi
be suitable axa blanc c'est juste pour
la photo il redore j après ok pas dispo
qu'ils ont fait pour moi parce qu'il est
dans cette situation quand même et mon
livre de trois fois que j'ai vu qu'ils
sessegnon qui réserve des hôtels pour
lui tout en rondeurs qui vient ça le 0-0
brossé du pied levé les bains les bains
turcs y entretient une image pour
provoquer qui serait payé 15 minutes
avec lui que je trouve quand même cool
avec ces gars là c'est qu'ils étaient
connus sur le tartan dans sa vie dans la
trentaine
puis l'idée dans l'armée je pense qu'il
ya une vie relativement normale même qui
dit qu'il n'y avait pas nécessairement
de succès que les filles ou quoi que ce
soit pis si souvent souvent ceux qui
vont virer
plus bizarre ou b qui vont mal viré
c'est quand vraiment gentils comme
bagdad d'apple c'est comme tout moche
lui andré qui est natif du sport s'est
pas détaché avec ce pas rationnel
totalement puis lui trouve ça drôle
cueilli rendu qu'il fait payer pour
aller au et de trouver d'autres partout
métis parce que autres certaines routes
au québec
ainsi nous on y suivis tout ceci avec
une bande-son poursuivent ils sont sûrs
et cac 40 millions personnes qui de
suisse et en démesure est démesuré fake
lui pour lui
tindouf conviés au québec a couvert
l'épicerie des porte à faux vis de mon
budget ils nous reconnaissent de nuit
c'est partout dans le monde tout le
temps tout le temps stern a aucun de vie
privée ce celle hall a que lui qui
viennent chez nous ils voient les pieds
relaxe puis le soir ils s'en vont à
l'hôtel puis s'en vont manger un bon
resto thème en essais et justin bieber
on parle de tout c'est un gars le savent
ils c'est catastrophe weekly le bateau
russe et golo silva mario se brouillent
line up de 50 personnes qui ne la tente
qu'ils veulent tu es aussi sont
surexposés ce monde le fait que moi
j'adore j'adore être suivie si par
madame hadja puis deuxièmement j'aime
j'aime faire vivre un quotidien pour
différents de du monde qui ont un emploi
plus réduit dit qu'il n'y ait pas que je
pense que c'est divertissant mais de là
à être suivie est celle suivie par les 7
millions personnes qu'on est je pense
que je trouverais ça ben jelloun risque
de pressions sociales énormes de tout
d'un petit geste mais bruxelles est chez
eux
il faut qu'ils soient en python part de
lui dit senna ne sait pas encore s'il
l'on sait ça c'est du film un nom niveau
que jean
t'as même pas de besoin et de fait un
must et jugeant lots ouais système vidéo
de cristiano ronaldo qui est qui le losc
avait suivi suivi sur instagram billets
dans un café à porto effectifs chez eux
puis il est un plan séquence à deux
minutes il ya un quand deux séries fille
qui se prennent avec lui mais y est pas
il pas en train de signer un livre en
prenant les selphy dispositif et il est
dans un café avec son pote à être bien
relax et puis le laisser lé fils de mon
art et puis l'intérêt qu'ils ont un
point de vue peut passer chiale thème je
vous restez tout ce temps après au moins
une ou deux dans l'instant et nous le
monde sont mais parce que des surfeurs
dept lamont 10 en caisse il vise 10 je
le reverrai jamais je veux une photo je
m'en apprendre autant que lui kitty
d'alors tight c'est normal puis même
tous ces gens racontent tout le temps
dans le boue dans la tête de beaucoup de
monde c'est normal que je veux ma photo
c'est ouais c'est normal pour les autres
dit moi ça me fait plaisir parce qu'elle
monnayait nous fait si ça c'est pas de
calais tantôt c'est pas des mesures ces
deux par super c'est que mouloud et
maintenant c'est sûr que s'ils voyagent
en événements jeu matin là oui c'est ça
ces niveaux extrêmes carli genoa est
venu chez nous cette semaine
ça doit être maître c'est tellement ça
c'est quand même tellement ils sont
déplacés pour elle c'est une catastrophe
ces genres est là le pot de vie puis
elle ses footings chipadze elle partout
sa planète ne peut pas aller nulle part
ça je trouve mexique cette semaine avec
un x oxo ouais je me suis tu cries beach
de vue d'une fois le parce que les
québécois sa plage mais comme après
personne personne qu'un labo pis il ya
des élingues le monde sont dans des
hôtels pire des mondes images de
commencer fust fait que tu voulais
quelque chose que je pense que
j'aimerais me repose beaucoup pleut pas
le bon mais ma job c'est vente des
billets le fait que lens de bouche mais
bon ça fait quel seulement d'aller qui
se pavanent interactions normal c'est le
monde sont aussi veut d'être que toit
fixe elle s'affaiblit cliquer oui exact
majeur sur 50 pays
normalement ça fait lui sa vie est finie
ça la mer exemple c'est je pense que ça
avec une fille qui est une chanteuse et
où il le fréquente et hier c'était comme
relativement bas que ça c'est la vie de
ce pied au bishop j'envoie plaindre des
martingales risques de ce qu'elle est
c'est l'idole des jeunes qui ont suivi
par 20 millions personnes ne peuvent pas
se déplacer c'est celle au factice pour
se souvient que c'est
c'est vraiment triste la bicis et des
services tss state puis le monde dans le
monde amusé quand est suivi comme sur
tout le monde dit écoute est inspirant
et chante des chansons ils sont
tellement attachés à toi et y ont écouté
ça pendant que leurs parents y venait de
divorcer que sa mère est à mort d'un
cacique en paca qui vont voir l'artiste
c'est long pour l'artiste la ccj pas
content mais c'est l'eau ce phrasé à
cause de toi jéjé notre j'y passe à
travers
c'est comme ces malades mais t'imagines
la pression que la personne à semaine
c'est moi le manga qui des fois qu'il a
été mandaté mon image comme
ces malades sur ce fou c'est l'os et
palau négatif ou négativement mais c'est
l'eau comme met de la pression tu veux
tout à performer puis pas que j'imagine
même pas où tu sais c'est un niveau
justin bieber il ya eu des briques d'un
seul states jeu par la saison quand même
cruellement
il reste atone c'est fini crier arrêtez
de crier coût de ces fleuves crier trop
le fait ses débuts ce que fait que c'est
cela la parental de shy'm est ce pour
revenir dans des zones qui est un gow 3
et ben normal pour pas tout mais quand
il parle mais c'est jusqu'à une image
qui projette de la femme qui est
beaucoup critiqué paris sqi mais même si
lui personnellement fait mal à personne
ça fait un peu du mal à l'image de la
femme le pays du monde parce que
justement on parle de responsabilité
qu'un tissu par autant de personnes dans
une influence sur l'amendé aurait raison
sauf que je l'aï vécu avec lui les
livres ni chez nous toutes les filles
veulent être avec comme qui vient devant
la salle audio bonnes feuilles sur les
fautes adan qui comme le reste
car moi j'ai vu du monde sans pitié
devant cas d'acte se fait d'ailleurs
encore une fois le 1%
mais déjà d'autres pôles et je vais pas
en douter landos et la responsabilité
sociale de l'artiste que je l'invite
pour son talent parce que un c'est bon
pot pour faire parler mais si j'ai fait
venir un boxeur de deux ans qui
s'appelle floyd mayweather qui est le
plus dur à boxer histoire sa femme qui
jalonnent zéro sauf que les gosses et un
dépliant zatler sa planète puis j'ai eu
la chance de le faire n'est pas je
devais venu mais c'est à dire jamais
mais je resterai avec mais je payais
pourquoi ces combos parce que justin
ebanga athlètes puis de l'autre côté
c'est un truc qui endosse paul et
jacques je veux non pilote de l'autre
côté de 10 mois mais tu le paies bonne
et chez vous oui mais pas pour ceux pour
l'autre chose mais je comprenne mon
parti met un peu les choses la vie
privée vie publique et ce même s'il
savait complexe maman née
si comme cai on demande parce que le
monde veulent quand même le voir je me
dis sur second service parce qu'ils
veulent pas venez mecs qui viennent peau
mais je veux pas que le monde y pense
que j'endosse tout et comme le monde
mais ton qui borde la belge li qui font
du shotgun qu'ils vont trouver des gens
pour lebron dessus mais la personne a pu
faire pareil même source
josiane le mettons le ces photos qui
seront il ya tout dans un sport avec
quatre feuilletons nul avec des codes
couleurs sans ses filets c'est qui
ci-dessus des fait normal dit modeste
des escortes s'est fait ben normal
exemple quand qui est venu
au beach club d'un esprit mains de
taquin de grosses entourage puis tout
son entourage ont beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent avec ce point de faradje autres
jets life maintenant il raconte cette
fille qui aime se faire les partis qui
veulent voyager avec elodie 70 monde
half ont péri quand vous obtenez vous
retournez chez vous et que l'effet que
tu vois c'est du monde qui parsèment de
trois semaines avec sa blonde si elle a
beaucoup d'amis qui jouent avec une
grosse entourage puis d'annecy paulson
toutes les partitions un migrant
entourage à monter jusque puis ils m'ont
tout le temps et il ya plus de gros cas
fictif avec lui le dieu lui c'est ce
voyage en toute rigueur qui voyagent
avec toi avec un petit cheval effet que
tu vois c'est les blonds ou legault la
fille cargo woippy bla bla bla face qu
il fallait que tous ses amis dont tout
le monde lui c'est vraiment
l'entourage tout le temps tout le temps
c'était déjà mais de ceux jamais jamais
jamais que son tour manager c'est son
meilleur ami son chauffeur c'est son ami
d'enfance que les entourages go life et
comme blisko mène tout le temps les paye
jamais rien parce qu'ils savent sur des
yards de ses amis pierre deschamps jboss
instagram six heures plus tôt ne vous
continuez qui tombent et les voyages
vont nous donner cette nouvelle maison
qui est énorme
et puis il fait pas mal tout son contenu
labo mais il ya tout le temps quatre
symboles qui par un genre de tournée
mondiale
c'est fou ça c'est fascinant comme un
lieu dans le fond il fait son argent
initiale en pot que pouvait bien pour
que puis 6,2 de jeux vidéo a pas de
vidéo mais de paris un gros pari en
ligne mais
une fois que cet argent-là de base avait
été fait
comment est ce que je veux dire il fait
pas de had sur son compte instagram
c'est juste en étant payé pour de
l'événementiel seule chose qui fait ceux
qui se promènent de bord en bord de
place en place de ville et d'hôtels s'il
ya beaucoup d'auteurs d'horizon qui
était aussi pour les faire la promotion
ou des conseillers ses mérites mais
c'est même pas des add qui fait il fait
je sais que la géorgie s'est de plus à
vue c'est le cas ça attire le monde que
lui soient les annonces que dans dix ans
il va aussi du luxe une trop cher puis
tout le monde qui je suis c'est tout des
méga vedette qui ont toutes beaucoup
d'argent fac il sera ya par croatie bain
de tama tiësto voltex tribalisme dans
les contacts de styles entre le jeu de
l'oie son prochain ouais si je sue c'est
sa ville fait que céder c'est pas apte
par ce cadeau seriez balaya une
compagnie de packs de chansons à la fois
comme ça mais c'est pas des artistes à
lui que c'est beau il ya donc à produire
dans ses passes à poissons brent et tu
verras jamais qu'un point qu'un constat
parler tu disais que tu cherchais des
gens pour justement prendre un peu la
relève tête haute du beach club parce
que toi tu avais tu m j'ai plein de
projets qui s'en viennent qu'à ce moment
là j'ai pas encore de quoi tu parles
ensuite est arrivé xo xo est arrivé ton
livre qu'on a parlé tantôt et à briser
la boisson la boisson est arrivé le
linge une course dans la terre elle a
explosé ces affaires de côté
premièrement et xo xo est arrivé commun
comment c'est arrivé
c'est simple
j'ai eu trois ans shaw qui s'appelait
biche loeb a zot bien vivre à 12 heures
lot 2 j'avais beaucoup beaucoup de
misère à bord des commandes stable à
cause de l'image tout se mêle aux
réseaux sociaux ont explosé puis ce qui
devait arriver arriva des compagnies
nous ont approchés justement pour l'expo
jeu et vidéotron m'approche qui me
disent on est vraiment intéressante
commente ce type tout ce petit monde à
ma taille des autoroutes un groupe qui
moi depuis tout jeune que je négocie des
contrats dans les géôles tout ce qui
s'est dit et quand catch s'engage dans
quelque chose avec une compagnie tels
que paul goût et dallas et d'argent
devant mu c'est pô juste et donne
l'argent c'est un partenaire tous à la
main puis comme je pense que ton
business pour pousser à amiens c'est du
donnant donnant avec ici donne l'argent
ce parce que ça vaut quelque chose
brisons là quelqu'un qui m'ont dit ça
ils m'ont dit on sans me chez vous on
voit par une heure et puis on va voir
après maints cette année là je n'avais
pas le goût d'aller chez compétiteurs
parce que quebecor soit une entreprise
que jamais beaucoup quelques thèmes que
tu aimes le bonobo
c'est une compagnie qui fait vivre
quinze mille familles c'est une des
compagnies les plus riches au canada ils
sont partout puis il ya personne qui
sous-traité puis sous payé la baule ces
gens vraiment belle compagnie pour une
entreprise comme moi c'est un exemple
si un jour j'ai un jeu sera la taille
d'une compagnie comme quebecor j'ai
monté je dois vraiment être content
c'est juste comme ça c'est sûr que tu es
ouvert à la critique de gauche à droite
toute surface qu'à vide autrement dit ça
j'ai juste dit que je revenais pas je
suis compétiteur parce que vidéotron
bien sûr le c'était bien tout ça mais je
marche avec bell avec dell et avec lui
les deux dernières années du beach club
qui je voulais pas je suis pas parti
d'ado pour animer une table je n'avais
jamais eu une discussion avec avec
québec en othe que vidéotron c'est une
décision purement business argent rien
d'autre puis de fil en aiguille quand
mon contrat finit avec avec la compagnie
audition faisait mouche ou beach club
interview - approcher parce que ça
faisait quand je travaillais que les
autres ils voyaient ce que je te garde
la foi ces réseaux sociaux pour
vidéotron il était content tout ce
qu'ils ont commencé à en parler de ce
monde novembre décembre on aimerait
savoir de téléréalité puis bla bla bla
tout ce qu'ils ont développé un concept
qui me l'ont demandé puis l'euro que
j'avais et que j'ai dans cette émission
là c'est ce que je suis dans la ville où
je reçois un bon budget organise des
événements fait que je trouve ça très
très cool
puis c'est difficile parce qu'on a un
nouveau concept la case erreur est pas
facile le chou est pas facile à
comprendre beaucoup quand de beaucoup de
trucs aléatoire sûr que je pense que de
semaine en semaine c'est des meilleurs
sinon le meilleur
puis le monde le monde qui nous suivent
depuis qu'ils ont décroché au début
parce que c'était too much
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de très très bons
commentaires
aujourd'hui des mauvais ou succès mais
correct ça fait partie de la game mais
bon on est juste là pour tout le monde
s'améliorer puis moi
moche là pour faire un bon show que je
pense que je fais un bon show taxé comme
ce que l'expulsion est arrivé puis
j'espère qu'on va laisser une chance au
show de se développer
je pense que c'est difficile pour pour
un nouveau show de télé-réalité au
québec d'arriver au québec parce qu'au
québec il y avait une télé c'était au
des légendes d'iodé c'est tellement rare
d ouais
l'équipe de prod lodetti c'est la même
demain hui ça fait dix ans que c'est la
même gang ça fait dix ans qu'ils sont
habitués de gérer avec x limites
budgétaires nous et on s'attend que la
limite budgétaire ait été levée au mais
c'est de gérer avec ce commentaire fait
pour faire la meilleure production value
avec expulsé puis au québec tu arrives
avec le nouveau concept puis
automatiquement tu vas être comparés
l'hexagone note qui est au début tu
attaques et je veux même pas déçu parce
que c'est pas vrai si on t'a 2018 s'agit
pas là même un dollar juste moi j'écoute
rodez j'écoute extrusion puis jetant un
fan des deux postes infectés les
réalités d'un glyphe à la télé réalité
qui veulent écouter écouter double
système sur tulle m c'est pas vrai que
c'est une compétition et c'est plus
juste un achat de codes des côtes n'ont
pu c'est le web c'est si c'est ça a
tourné
mais oui puis nous
avec extraction est sûr que billy qu on
est là le show le plus écouté il ya
plein l'abattement qui se vend tout acte
et c'est tellement un gros grosse
machine ses gros show là que manette
c'est pas juste c'est tout le monde sic
explique sa salle existe même si on n'a
pas les meilleures cotes d'écouté c'est
pas vrai que le monde n'écoute peau qui
se poseraient que le monde aime possible
c'est chaud qui est tellement d'avoir
amélioré mais on le sait normal c'est la
première ça c'est normal qu'ils étaient
11 janvier une première saison qu'on est
dans une zone grise avec la télé la
façon de consommer plutôt taxer de mon
écoute sur leur téléphone le monde
écoute sa tv moi j'avais même pas de
tombe aux distributeurs la dépense est
le genre d un pas que je peux l'écouter
expulsions stop your boots troupe temps
tu peux pas l'écouter sur le web parce
qu'il veut des abonnements sayabec arrêt
qui veulent vendre du contenu puis je
comprends qu'on sait faire cesser plus
c'est pas juste parce que exactement
c'est un don truc sopi proches trop
secours pour les québécois on est des
femmes de télé réalité ici au mans 2-2
bonne pile à extinction s'améliore de
semaine en semaine et comme dit ou d où
cet enfant c'est tellement beau
tellement bien fait
nous aussi c'est juste qu'il faut que tu
apprennes à la canaille pc on veut pas
faire la même chose
les premières semaines seulement qu'ils
disent et les codes des côtes de l'élite
dé certaines critiques quitté tôt mitigé
c'est mais si je me souviens bien aux
dés l'an passé les premières semaines il
ya des réactions le viroin cotes
d'écouté décevantes d'ananas
quel type de show bis pourrait on
l'oublié mais les premières semaines de
show le passé moi je me souviens qu'il
ya des trucs au niveau de la technique
de folie sont attendus attentivement
parce que mes amis italiens puis je
regarde avec un oeil critique parce que
je connais sur mes tiges sont attentifs
à audard sortait détail des gens
l'achètent et du flou est ce qu'ils sont
et bond sa part le pis c'est vraiment
mieux le destin ips à s'éroder vraiment
bien
durant la saison les chocs son bébé tout
mettre ses coûts d'extraction de semaine
en semaine
c'est un peu la même chose normale parce
que j'ai une équipe technique c'est pas
des robots automatiquement son sacoche
les tice parce que le nom on le vit mais
monsieur maintenant qu'ils accrochent
seraient ils pensent que c'est ce
qu'explique des doigts et le monde les
80 personnes qui dorment pas bien gigean
c'est des machines mais tout le monde
n'y a personne sur plateau tu veux pas
que les choses reviennent parce que y'a
pas des titres parce que aussi on est
dans un média qui était vo qui étaient
habitués de faire d'autres annoncés mais
un haut cadre des coûts' était comparé
aux dés sont pas mauvaises de jeu
distincts première année on est à peu
près égale le web est très fort aussi on
est parti de zéro à 75 en un mot on est
un nouveau show rodé ça fait dix ans
qu'ils jouent à rien aux deux jours les
deux choses sont très bons mais je pense
que le note mérite même pas de deuxième
chance mérite une chance de se faire
vengeance
c'est chaud questionne deuxième saison
d'un conseil doit être modifié ils vont
peut-être avoir moins de candidats ou
peu importe mais il va voir les
améliorations comme audi ont fait
pendant des années et on se rappelle que
vous distincts qui tourne à terrebonne
au début il y avait 300 personnes qui
n'écoutaient parce que dalton y avait là
on ce beau conte mais le chaîne
spécialisée 2000 télé réalité partout
dans le monde comme on écoute les big
brother et un bleu de m j'avais 22 ans
je dis on n'avait pas accès à ce matin
sans attendre sans contact
et puis la voix de l'est le mode 2d
coaching c'est clément qui vont
s'attaquer au complet dans un mois on a
ce qu ils veulent tous les arbres ça se
mesure plus un classement plus à bozouls
des côtes l'habilité ça se mesure aussi
en vente parce que c'est une business
les ventes dans notre show sont très
bonne tout le monde est affiché avec soi
puis s'est t on dit il est aussi plus
toutes les toutes les chaînes
il doit se renouveler doivent aller
chercher une veine clientèle s'ils
veulent ramener les jeunes qui écoutent
tout genre de truc là à la tv il faut
absolument qu'il brise le moule par
kelly cinq cent mille personnes 120
personnes qui nous écoutent par semaine
et de la nouvelle clientèle et on joue
après la poule aux oeufs d'or
comme ce que vous connaissez quelqu'un
d'autre qui coûte à tv mag reçoit pas
leur boulot dodo
pas moi non pas que des jeux toute la
récolte des jeux moins chaud je comptais
le chou est bon pied qu'est ce que ce
que tu fais des des critiques qui
reprocher les assure valises sur
valorisation de la présence des médias
sociaux main t on entendu parler
beaucoup mais je rappelle j'écoutais la
première pizza l'esprit le fameux par
satellite le fameux te passer de l'aide
sur instagram fait maintenant chez vous
la face des trois fait plus qu est ce
que tu es décédé ces critiques laisse
que c est ce que c'est je pense mériter
mérité les critiques qui la critiquent
méchante non jamais mais la critique du
conseil contre les chaumes et un wii
puis je pense que toute l'équipe de prod
à une autre car qu'on a fini chaud en
été comme c'est bon mais parce que c'est
le pire on a perdu beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes à cause de ce show le de ce
clash pression parce qu'il y avait une
espèce d'arbre et manque en fait
ok c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
quoi c'est parce qu'on est tellement
habitué que la première ça soit le tapis
rouge
le si le ce puis l'on voulait vraiment
faire changement on peu de changements
mais peut-être un peu trop puis
mais mais dans le concept ça prend quand
même la grande sélection tout l'été ça
prend une sélection de candidats est ce
qu'il y avait tellement gros base à ce
qu'on aurait pu la faire jouer ses
réseaux sociaux pipe et comme on était
au budget dans tout était réalité les
tapis rouges de les lui rendre honneur
c'est ce que j'aime le moins
bercy c'est souvent ce qui - vraiment
attirant ceci même aux destinées au
prince était malade le tapis rouge tout
néons 10 et une mallette en mal en effet
les fip illégaux sont battus la sphère
de l'égibilité son genre il faut que tu
ailles tavannes be tout ce puits en y
dorment dans des années qu'il faut pas
qu'ils vendent que ce soit un gouffre
celle de cette année c'est 24 fait 5 2
les prochaines sans ôter des travaux
avec des équipes mixtes à votre choix
comme si c'était une première
puis je pense que tout le monde a
réalisé que c'était pas mal nous a fait
mal parce qu'après ça commence le show
est bon mais c'est moi j'écoutais la
première je fait sacrément sedan mais
intense tout faire j'écoutais le
l'épisode ici souche peut troquer sur
internet puis fait six finales manquées
mais c'est quand même sorti finalement
c'est pour jean christophe pacaud
d'autre part tout tombe dans un
diffuseur aussi kiki qu'on n'y est pas
là pour choquer ils l'ont fait ils font
tout le temps tu es bien ils font tout
cas une belle production le monde diem
les choux qui font pas que je n'ai pas
été écouté cette semaine deux qui
étaient ses thèmes et ses nominations
des jumeaux dont quelques uns des deux
jumeaux qui parle c'est les 25 dernières
minutes
c'est de la grosse grosse tv
d'élimination le genre je laissais moins
d'un an des jeux d'écouter la musique
touche t comme conséquence la seule
chance mais les problèmes comme c'était
tantôt je pense que moi justement
j'écoutais le premier j'écoutais
l'épisode 6 pilotes fois sur deux c'est
encore un concept qui s'est surpassé la
critique principale c'est que c'est dur
d'embarquer cod y acheter les lecteurs
ont frappé sa blonde qui l'ont pas
écoutée encore depuis la saison mettez y
étaient 38 pilotes sont probablement
accroché type comprend concept suite qui
titre embarquée pijet une fois tous les
côtés une fois le gg écoutez maintenant
l'épisode 6 2
d'ex opus chapeau que j'ai pas adopté la
suite je comprends pas ce qu'elle était
perso moi je pense que peut-être trop
candide de ces liseuses toute attache -
les trois équipes très sain il ya trois
conseillers doit - accueil - qui est
retombé depuis les émeutes aux fantômes
on a trois groupes de filles puis à
toutes les semaines pour organiser des
marches mains de mr porter avec chacun
de nos groupes illégaux ils font les
groupes ils vont voir un coup de coeur
où il ya c'est d'aller rencontrer des
filles qui ont pas connu avec moi cette
semaine je trouve excellent 15,8 en
espagne qu'ils avaient fait à montréal
tant que les gosses à split les gays
choisissent le parti vert qui
choisissent la porte et ben ça n'est pas
des super des fossés des ferries qui
dessert cargo qui veulent qu'ils
viennent plutôt de ceux qui à la fin le
but c'est que chacun dans notre groupe
on avait un coffre-fort qui voit se
rendent en finale mais là ce moment vu
chez moi m'a raconté qu'un de ses
conseillers généraux encore dans mon
monde
bien sûr mais
le concept est quand même 5 c'est juste
que c'est la plus petite du début se
comprend peau je pense que c'est un tout
et tout le monde s'en rend compte en ce
moment faudra justement exactement mais
je pense que le monde qui l'écoutent
lherm
c'est sûr qu'il ya un petit ce parce
qu'encore une fois je vois des
commentaires audio mais sa peau c'est
comme si tu es côtes raides passer par
un goulot deux buts et des doubles des
réalités avec beaucoup moins de comment
je pourrais ne soit pas moins de
diamants mais c'est beaucoup moins deux
chicanes parce que les gros gagnants
mais entre les deux groupes i say say
jusqu'à rodez ils sont armés mais un
autre enseignement oui les filles
mettons dans mon groupe une fille qui
tripent sur go dans l'autre groupe si
les filles vont se désister je raconte
pas il sera content jamais cessé il se
raconte une fois par semaine sont comme
on dirait qu'ils veulent pas parler wade
veut c'est qu'ils mentent mais même si
ce fait que le moi j'adore ça me fait un
peu chier parce que j'adore j'adore le
show parce que je suis des piments jeune
viking thème se fasse bien si je voulais
dire parce que j'ai l'impression que moi
quand j'ai entendu le show j'ai entendu
parler de chaud j'étais là qui allie va
être conseiller je me disais il va être
plus un membre de la prod
il met des pentes et d'un manque de la
prod mais on dirait que tu es dans ce
show le trio de keith un candidat de
tellement souvent je te revois j'opte
sais pas qu'est ce que tu vas faire
dénoncer une compétition sans fin avec
un utilisateur parce que les coupures
dans leur groupe sont d'un bruit de qte
je m'en fous je vais perdre fakaté le
site tellement de stratégie c'est de
l'alliance c'est plus un show comme ça
je pense de son choix stratégique parce
que c'est à eau des cartouches de la
stratégie c'est mal vu
nous c'est un jeu le dessus qu'il faut
que je change de dénomination
il faut que les filles façon un des lacs
légaux de protéger cette équipe mais
plutôt à 4 embarque deux des six jours
soit le plus noir l'élimination un
groupe tata belle négociations c'est
plus que jamais une fille qui dit et je
vais aller beach et dans son dos en arts
ina se foule pas ce que tu es pendant
même maison quand t'as que mes mollets
jaillit tellement qui a eu pizza bateau
d'entrer dans le jeu je les déteste dit
bouge ta un bon tricheurs est au jeu le
genre je parle à apprendre à se défaire
parler pour savoir qu'est ce que ça dit
pts ce parti autres cépages chef aq
alpha clé aujourd'hui toujours sont
année parce que je me mets le nez
partout plage face à dax calif si vous
ne savez plus lobster a déjà acté
j'arrive à lindau puis moi j'essaie de
tout ça vos piles sont franches et on
m'a dit tu devrais le coach rex et
cycliques ou d'assécher le sait vraiment
plus tôt c'est pas comme l'euro dj
disciplinaire lui plat ou huit ans pas
moins dangereux pigeonnant prenois bon
et quand jean carzou la porte
quand je vois par l'ofev bon le livre
cette semaine
qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que le
challenge il faut je protège tout le
monde
ok tu as vraiment carabins oui parce
qu'elle est les faits et hitch ta tâche
si sa tâche pour gossip us mode avec les
boys même s'il y en a un ou deux qui me
tape sénat robert parce que cas qui
viennent à mes événements faut que trop
socheat cas qui reviennent au penthouse
maquis des analystes un malade encore
fait
sebha est pile et confessionnelles stade
ils sont bons parce qu'on beach un peu
dans le doute tout le monde bonne guerre
mais mouche d'un jeu vous georges rail
va se passer ça j'avais demandé que
satan pas j'adore ça m'empêche paumé
george reeves que liam dans mon groupe
fenice cammas thématiques jusqu'à ses
joueurs qu'en jetant à rodez quand je
t'ai la baule petit j'imagine si
sensiblement la même chose parce que tu
te dis ribard une élimination
ces rappels j'avais de la misère à
m'endormir parce que ça tournait jeu
sans arrêt c'est sûr vous êtes et ce que
vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes enregistré d'avant
noël dans le fond oui mais à cause du
montage pas le temps pour les missions
qu'on va voir mercredi est disponible
depuis mercredi pensée sur le téléphone
ktm avec vidéotron
c'est encore une fois une diffusion
compliqué puis juste un petit avantage
part je pense qu'on perd mais pense pas
que je le sais on perd beaucoup de cotes
d'écouté vais à kolda dessus parce qu'il
ya quand même je peux poser des chiffres
mais des dizaines de personnes qu'ils
voient à 20 c'est vrai le pen ça brûle
le porge fait que tout arrive à djabla
mais petit à petit j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup de temps partagé des centaines
de commentaires comme ceux par semaine
comment mon ami me dit que du bien et
elle sait que tu as mais d'un autre côté
on y vend des abonnements font de
l'argent avec ce sabot bay choqué les
codes des côtes fac d'histoire un gros
mélange
je pense que c'est aussi ça le nuit ou
un peu au chaud même si le monde le
monde qui paye 24 telle onde avance
people s'est claqué fac
maintenant l'heure mercredi le chant
profane est à 9 heures et une telle
chose de la semaine prochaine puis le
dimanche tu ne sors que le v10 contacter
la tellement de réécoute tout sûr que
le chiffre exact complètement chiffres
du monde qui dégoûte atv des vieux
journaliste drogue des côtes des côtes
comme si on est en 2006 comme son petit
un district 31 ça s'écoute atv je suis
pas qu'elle joue parce que c'est mon
père qui les groupes tous mais aude et
moi je les écoute il est fait codé soit
disponible gratuitement en ligne
c'est peut-être pas la chose la plus
payante mais c'est sûr que ça contribue
énormément au boss se remboursant pour
soeur puis je pense que tout le monde
est bien d'accord ac / fax et surtout
des petits ajustements mais on a deux
très bon show late heavy québécoise est
vraiment vraiment chanceux d'abord c'est
parce que en 2012 ça coûte encore très
très cher il ya de moins en moins de
commanditaires tout le monde y nous
approchent la façon de publiciser
complètement différent avec des gens
qu'on a encore des grosses prod mais on
est vraiment chanceux face cachée dans
le dos tout le monde c'est pas bon pour
personne ni des grosses grosses équipes
qui travaillent là dessus ça va vivre
pleinement depuis le monde travaille
fort avec sa femme inquiète on shoote à
chier 4 le regarder juste la première ou
15 minutes
cc c'est plate mais gardent ça fait
parti de rien et puis on s'améliore on
fait un bon chocolat après puis d'année
en année si j'avais pu je t'assure et
d'apprenants ou 12 ans on l'a gardé un
métier mais prouve notamment par alex
chose avec aude et tantôt sais pas si
c'est la même affaire puis l'impression
que le public avait coûté aux dés les
années d'avancé la première la deuxième
saison c'est quand même différent par et
la proposition l'an passé avec au départ
mappy le public est habitué
donc en fait en dehors ce maudit public
en transe pas négatif dos et ses polos
occupation double qu'on connaît na na
nana na na
il faut le demander à décrocher mais il
faut le nouveau monde tu as découvert ce
qui avait jamais écouté ceux qui sont
mis à crochets factice jeu de trouver
son public ou ses médailles peut être
une voie cette année il sera encore
milliard et les critiques montent ya
encore plus de monde la base est encore
plus gros mais
c'est normal c'est très très rare que
dans n'importe quoi quatre travaillent
fort pour tous et on produit que ça soit
sûr que ça soit une émission tv
c'est très rare que ça grossit pas avec
les années passées la communauté grossit
grossit aussi aussi jusque là on a un
gros buzz au début puis s'étoffe avoir
la pression d'un gros buzz domaines qui
devront livrer un show de première année
c'est c'est compliqué ça vous fait un
podcast la migration en une semaine en
semaine les détails stupide laquelle
était mis ko 6e ben c'est la même chose
c'est là on est dans un an on a cédé
rentrer dans un rond notre soulier
corypha crypte d'année prochaine
c'est ça ça se place au désir ça fait ça
fait 7 5
on est en voyage en norvège avec
elisabeth riou belle fille je t'ai pas
jaloux pas tout
c'était vraiment c'était vraiment
vraiment le fun mais va amener ont
notamment conduit qu'on avait des bonnes
sections 56 heures dans un champ
sept jours puis puis elisabeth qui
disait puis prend la main que tu vas te
reconnaître la danse ça me fait penser à
chaque entité oms a lyon tout le temps
ils arrêtent a dit kaka s'est lancé en
affaires avec juste 16 ans puis à celle
antisec homme entreprenant une compagne
maillot puis à 10 j'en ai fait des
erreurs le j'en ai fait énormément qui
ont en fait sauf que ce qui fait que tu
es tu as du succès au final c'est que tu
refais pas deux fois
sabourin c'est que tu apprends exactes
sur toi business bastille ils habitent
là je la connais justement je pense qu'à
l'adapter
début 17 ou 18 la première année que
j'avais une biche tabou la deuxième d'un
thème différent je vois un shooting
photo chez nous bientôt y avait personne
qui a suivi qui à ma demande je me
rappelle plus jamais le maillot de
castres j'avais dit je suis comme
passeur ça va tellement con pipe tout
petit fils c'est un modèle s'est
affaissé une manche présence de machines
et audrey six ans entrepreneur et nous
l'avons au québec qui réalisent pas à
quel pour isabelle rioux c'est une femme
d'affaires extraordinaire tout le mérite
pour l as en bourse et qui suis un fan
fini de son modèle de r d ventes
utilisent habilement plus que 10 mai par
ce même si je te croise ici la folie
furieuse parce que c'est speed mais elle
a commencé calmement des cinq maillots
par semaine puis alors bien vu avec les
influenceurs peace iep sopi ashton s'est
rendue elle a le plus besoin de personne
je voudrais pas besoin je serai pas à
100% elle est vraiment rendu ailleurs
qu' on dirait que le monde est à prendre
au sérieux parce que cela ne fait p g
anticipe ce mais je te laisser
apparaître une drague on voudrait à tour
est tout sauf un sont bruns et courts
puis le monde qui a suivi le lem les
bacs thévenot si le pi ca delà il trop
extraverti de ses photos ses ouvres de
top et relax je pense que ces jeunes
g/100 g
c'est juste c'est juste pas apprendre à
parler comme ça mais comme le le assumer
en tant que personne qui réussit tu peux
parfois sensibles est arrivé bon témoin
depuis tout jeune que en étant très
précis grossesse pis dans mon petit
village le petit succès au fait que
j'étais habitué lci
bon oui pascal le tellement bien faible
mais non moi je trouve je trouve ça mal
ah oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ce que tu
racontes est sereine de 15,5 à la fois
que vous avez continent à l'autre
il ya tellement tellement d'erreurs des
robes des rangs avant d'avoir un petit
succès pic à succès taken qui le loge
pas bien mais dans l'autre la tasse en
dehors ça marche populaire à gauche tire
à droite il faut pour du place puis
théâtre après entrepreneurs au québec
c'est pas facile
puis le cache pas c'est pas facile pas
facile non plus que de côté mon attaque
et ils avaient tous les lits dont des
taxes et on ici on est ce un ping
partout dans le monde font qu'aller des
entrepôts partout et c'est le monde ils
comprennent pas à quel point c'est
compliqué il au monde réalise peau qu'à
défendre à la fête en vente je me
rappelle piquer nos deux ou trois mois
je tiens ce historique gilchrist et
coeur et on entrepose ses fous
il a par rapport à celle ci arrive d'en
sourire en australie choix pièce est
tellement business c'est même pas pour
le shopping cela va payer moins de taxes
et business business mais aussi pour les
costarmoricains se payer moins de taxes
s'empressant équipe 100% tant que non
moi j'ai tout mon respect puis je pense
que l'on ne savait pas si la baisse tout
en enfer à découvrir qu'ils méritent
beaucoup beaucoup de beaucoup plus d'eux
beauchemin par respect mais beaucoup
plus de mérite qu'elle est d'accord ça
m'amène à parler dont les films ont pas
rien quand j'ai fait la couverture
ces malades je me suis dit je me voyais
mal et je voulais avoir à parler
alternant comme peut le faire le ménage
ne voulais pas qu'ils tapent h ouverture
le titre c'est quoi cette merde de ces
malades
c'est ce biais je m'attendais à avoir
beaucoup beaucoup de commentaires
négatifs quand j'ai posté la montre
comme le transit de florence août à
déléguer concrétions leucatois les cours
bien qu'une casquette transparent que
justement nous produits dérivés c'était
une page très fourni et le titre parce
que mon pari ça ne fait pas ses amours
paris reicha tabarnak un clin d'oeil
c'est dans les premières pages
c'est important pour moi d'avoir cette
flopée de photophores parce que dans la
première page je ne mets pas là mais on
va commencer
l'entreprise fait la préface ces malades
puis je le relis 50 fois qu'est ce qui
n'a pas de bon sens pour moi c'est un
gros ballon en première page je te suit
la faute aux trucs parce que mon père et
j'explique ckoi est un entrepreneur au
québec ckoi est dans une famille qui a
réussi
je me plains pas parce que je dis c'est
que c'est pas facile pas parce que tu as
de l'argent qui est loin d'être le mot
parce que pil exemple les engagements de
bulletins le bishop on a perdu beaucoup
que l'argent les deux premières années
cette année c'est notre première année
rentable si si jamais c'est votre
première année rentable
wawatie c'est pire on a perdu beaucoup
d'argent
je pose un problème et c'est beaucoup
puis j'ai eu des gros disques sûrement
pas mon frappe des chikhates d'ici parce
que c'est pas l'argent des banques qu'on
risque c'est l'argent de toute la
famille depuis mon père et mon
grand-père ont réussi à piquer mais
depuis je travaille depuis qu'un tueur
en série un gros gros grès d'argent pour
nous
mais on n'a pas lâché milliards cette
année c'est ça prend pas le montrent pas
qu'ils se découragent c'est un peu ça
aussi dans le livre que j'explique topo
pour te décourages puis c'est tout et
proportionnelle nous on perdait beaucoup
d'argent mais on avait beaucoup très
humblement mais de l'autre côté du port
avec 100 piasses temps par 150 mètres a
perdu une fois mis ton tout
investissement mais faut pas te
décourages tu crois qu'on projet puisque
le monde dise c'est parce que le ski
compliqué en enfance et de faire
connaître son produit une fois qu'il
connut le tu peux commencer à faire de
l'argent puis rentable mais développe
l'enfant comme le beach aux bleus ça
coûte tellement cher c'est on le voit
acquérir ce sont maintenant je pense que
je mets sur instagram qu'un une semaine
un bon 20 millions de cadeaux dont la
pâle plus j'ai pas de restaurer un beach
club c'est un autre fou c'est exact
c'est fou c'est fou et on rigole journée
on était 150 375 employés sa coach à
ouvrir les portes le monde comprenne pas
fakty calmont ils me disent à ta bière
et deux classes et c'est la belgique 2-1
mais où est plus ouvrir les portes les
350 euros et folle aventure pas très bon
on nourrir au tacticien
je pense que le monde commence à
comprendre tu étais je fais ce oui on
fait du business mais qu on veut faire
l'argent mais j'aime tellement ce qu'est
le monde du x monde en ville depuis
toujours que j'ai là où j'en sors je
reçois le monde
james d'un monde puis si je peux faire
de l'argent exemple je préfère ma job
tant mieux il ya personne qui me dit as
tu une charte rochard tu fais de
l'argent ce monde 11 personnes et en a
produit les convainc comme sur son lit
parce que faut pas qu'ils mois prochain
aux éditions la semaine j'étais comme
vous lâche pas de quoi dans un peu
biographiques et gecam biographie j'ai
trente de musique est urgent que j'ai
rien à raconter là dedans petit je me
sentais mal ressenti un peu l'un postwar
l'adec sambre écrire un livre
mais j'ai tellement eu de bons
commentaires encore une fois mme
hedegaard qui préside absolue soleil qui
écrit la préface c'est comme pour moi
ces deux légendes ou vraiment content
puis ça motive encore plus puis je me
dis que
il ya d'autres choses qui font mal à les
jouer comme implantés dans des projets
de type 1 jusqu'à la recherche piste est
vraiment allé avec ce que tu connaissais
python histoire au pmc vraiment j'ai
tout appris sur le terrible j'ai tout
appris mon pad au hasard tout ce que
charbonnier je l'appris pluie qui je
donne beaucoup de beaucoup de trucs là
dedans que j'ai eue de mon père puis
bâti à ce moment sa salle évolue
tellement vite qu'on m'envoie la
business du plus comme avant c'est dans
un show d'avant rouge qu'on me payait
c'était chez nous tout seul c'est que
l'artiste qui va être hautement six mois
tu ne sais pas qu'il va sortir un homme
c'est tellement compliqué c'est juste
pour être beau le bouquet la plus gros
artistes la planète en ce moment la
région ni vendre des billets parce que
les labels gaulliste en avant le fait
que c'est vraiment d'avant j'imagine que
s'il va sortir un album d'entre eux tant
besoin d'avoir un boss c'est quoi oui
pas même d'un c'est un flop c'est un
flou c'est comme banques et ows qu'est
ce que je fais pas que tiède qui
demandent de l'argent
tabarnak 2d comme ça vaut la peine
d'un autre côté de ceux à qui ça va
faire une bonne pub même si je fais pas
d'argent si tu as chaud là au moins
c'est comme mes gosses les gates
tellement cher j'ai pas fait d'argent
sauf que les gueux qui regardent leurs
story tout le monde sur sa a fait un
buzz énorme puis tout le monde mettons
toutes les autres après qu'ils regardent
l'australie son genre si moi je les ai
vu le sang c'est tout comme souhaité
c'est comme ça aussi qu'on attire
d'autres artistes parce que l on doit à
pointe-calumet nous bouleverser ce 46e
j'arrête pas de peser pour que l'artiste
chez nous même s'ils payaient thé bio
sont en demande trouve un faux par année
puis foncé en show tac faut qu'il
choisisse la cathy cargo comme si
eastwood y aller aujourd'hui j'ai dans
le festival
c'est un amoureux du bitume à mourir
devant le testo qui commence ma place
préférée
journée gr le temps d'emmener l'équipe
tout j'étais à guy martin charisme deux
semaines il a écrit en box play
les griffons les plus gros festivals
romands les plus beaux clubs au monde
mais une vibe spéciale je sais pas
comment la décrire
mais il ya une faille spéciale au québec
que les artistes adorent qui doit mettre
le paquet oui vraiment vraiment vraiment
qu'ils pas le choix je veux tu es les
grilles sont tellement au dessus de tout
avouer que quand ils arrivent chez nous
joueur qui continue ses bonnes faut que
l'alcool soit 20 de la seconde qui
débarquent du jet à s'aguerrir à bagdad
un ca soins en pointe c'est ça ma job
fait que suivre une bouteille est pas
disponible ici ben jemâa vaucher pas ou
en ontario la trouvais ça me plaisait
même s'il vaut la mardi et qui a pris le
tallec est ce que j'ai demandé à ce
qu'on dit paul des groupes d'artistes de
même il faut faire beaucoup d'argent ça
me fait plaisir de leur faire plaisir
parce que d'autres l'ont fait président
en faveur de l'argent puis c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne puis viennent
tripes et avoir un fan tutte le matin et
en août au canada promener le place à
aller le thema temps ils veulent ils
sortent en même temps ils veulent aller
voir leurs fans
il ya nous aurons une coupe de place
dans l'ouest de la place à toronto
passants place aline que non c'est cool
on est chanceux on n'était pas le bon
moment puis l'animal et malone pas que
mon pari parce qu'à mon palais montcalm
n'ont pas été tellement crise quand j'ai
montré à quel point cet après midi à
étampes est tellement riche comme on est
loin d'un pick up il n'entend pas y
avait une côte d'ivoire et les immeubles
commerciaux immobiliers mitigés je me
rappelle d'une page de d'un quai la
question c'est qui se trouvait du titre
qui est genre je suis vraiment pas
content de ses droits parce que québec a
aussi font avec nico ils font un
documentaire sur moi qui sont le 18
novembre que milito qui j'avais proposé
le même si tu voulais pas/je la masse
infinie badji primo l'audacieux cache
bien mais ali grand merci merci beaucoup
d'être bien ce gars est pas de casse
gros gros merci même j'ai eu des
discussions je vous attends aubisque
lave au beach club c'est son image et je
fais un petit peu d'anxiété sociale des
moyens j'ai vite un petit peu ces
places-là ces endroits le mais que tu es
à force de me faire dire que ces malades
c'est sûr que je me suis enfin tout pour
que ce soit bien fait que c'était aussi
ça réussisse de confirmer déjà booké où
sont pas encore annoncés pas encore
annoncé mais tiède y parvenir à colmater
ce trou de play de dj comme ce que le
stop au canada c'est tout le temps chez
nous tant que c'est pas sûr à 100% mais
c'est très rare que et tiësto c'est très
rock sont en année il dit deux fois
cette année il y avait une résidence à
première fois au canada où va bien
fermer les gros artistes comme sur pied
[Musique]
c'est bien dit comme ça ça fait quand
libourne est vraiment sûr de vraiment
fine à dépenser plus et tombe enceinte
de six mois
pis son job qui relie migros est venu
l'accueillir vraiment g et mes soeurs
c'est drôle c'est que je vous dise
important qu ils y recevront 200 après
option d'argent qu'en libye comme ce
curieux les steppes
après c'est le genre beyoncé quelque
chose qui est possible c'est passé c'est
tout est possible c'est une question
d'argent c'est juste qu'avec la capacité
qu'ont été mon rêve c'est d'avoir
greenwood ramasser un des plus gros
vendeurs de billets au monde en ce
moment
xx très beau mais c'est un cap à 7000
est ce que ça vaut la peine tu peux
pauvre et je vend les billets 250 g à
chaque pas ce que lui ça me fait plaisir
de venir mais c'est pas vrai qu'il va
charger moins cher pour moi faire
plaisir ça demande un paquet pour ce qui
fait deux dates des soldes qui vient pas
chez nous mais on ne dit jamais jamais
je souhaite
[Musique]